in this USMLE Step 1 high yield video
let us talk about Cushing syndrome
Cushing syndrome is a condition which is
characterized by increased level of
cortisol in the blood this increase can
be caused by an internal cause such as
adrenal gland tumor or external cause
that is corticosteroid injections for
different Therapies
a patient with Cushing syndrome comes to
you in the clinic with a fatty hump
behind the back of neck round face
clinically known as Moon Facey easy
bruising and pink stretch marks known as
the purple stryer apart from that the
patient can present with low bone
density manifesting as osteoporosis high
blood pressure and type 2 diabetes
let's understand the biology behind the
Cushing syndrome
the main player in the biology is
cortisol
it is a steroid hormone produced by the
adrenal glands the small cap-like
structures sitting on the top of your
kidneys the main function of cortisol is
to regulate the body's response to
stress
other functions of cortisol are Patron
stress response include regulation of
metabolism separation of inflammation
and blood sugar regulation
cortisol levels vary in a day to night
fashion in our body a precise hormonal
axis regulates this variation in
hypothalamus there is a hormone that is
corticotrophin releasing hormone this
hormone goes and stimulates the
pituitary particularly the anterior
pituitary to release a hormone known as
ACTH that is
adrenocorticotrophic hormone this ACTH
goes to the adrenal gland and stimulates
the adrenal cortex to release the
cortisol hormone
the cortisol hormone in turn when in
high levels gives a negative feedback to
anterior pituitary decreasing the ACTH
levels and gives another negative
feedback to the hypothalamus decreasing
the crh levels
now if somehow this hormonal axis gets
deranged you get increased levels of
cortisol suppose you get a tumor at the
level of anterior pituitary there is an
anterior pituitary gland tumor or
pituitary adenoma in that case there
will be excess amount of ACTH which will
in turn lead to excess stimulation of
adrenal gland leading to more cortisol
production this condition is known as
Cushing's Disease which is a very
specific type of Cushing syndrome apart
from that there can be an adrenal gland
tumor that is an adrenal adenoma which
is a functional tumor and produces a lot
of
cortisol
apart from these two there can be a lot
of genetic and familial influences
leading to familial Cushing syndrome
now let's understand the pathophysiology
of Cushing's syndrome
the cortisol
impedes the bone forming activity by
promoting the osteoplastic activity this
leads to decrease in the density of
Bones leading to osteoporosis
apart from that cortisol suppresses all
almost all components of the immune
system leading to immunosuppression
and this in turn leads to increased risk
of infection
now this decrease in immune system in
one hand leads to decrease in
inflammation whereas it increases the
risk of infection on the other hand so
at many a times the risk benefit
analysis of using cortisol as a
therapeutic agent becomes a very
daunting decision
now apart from making
your body more susceptible to infection
the cortisol
increasing cortisol
down regulates the GnRH or gonadotrophic
releasing hormone
secreted from the hypothalamus this down
regulation of GnRH leads to decreased
sexual function of testis and overly
leading to decreased libido decreased
fertility functions
let's Now understand what is the how we
diagnose Cushing syndrome in clinics
there are two main tests that we do that
is the 24 hour urinary cortisol test it
measures the amount of cortisol
excretion in the urine over 24 hours
if the levels are higher than 550 to 100
micrograms per day in an adult that
suggests the presence of a hyper
cortisolmia in the blood which may
indicate towards the Cushing syndrome
apart from that another test that we
have is a low dose dexamethasone
separation test
here we give dexamethasone to a patient
and then we take a blood for screening
of cortisol if low cortisol is present
then the test is taken as normal if High
cortisol is present that indicates
towards Cushing syndrome we will talk
about this dexamethasone separation test
in a separate video in details
now let's come to the treatment of
Cushing syndrome now certain medications
can be used such as Ketoconazole to
control the excessive production of
cortisol but the definite management
include surgical resection of pituitary
adenoma or an adrenalectomy for an
adrenal tumor I hope by now you have
understood the idea of Cushing syndrome
if you have enjoyed our videos you can
go and check out our Facebook page and
Instagram to get high quality notes and
flashcards
the link will be in the description box
below also so so that we can continue to
make high quality educational content
for free you can use the super thanks
icon to support our channel the icon
will be on the bottom right corner of
the video you can pay by using paytm
PayPal or UPI also you can support us on
our patreon page and you can scan the QR
for payment
if you wish to connect you can use the
following links in the description and
for medicine related content you can
follow the nerd medic on YouTube until
then bye bye see you in the next one